rihanna and asap rocky are still going
strong
i couldn't tell you how happy i am the
couple recently enjoyed a date night at
barcade
in new york city and weren't shy about
showing a little
like i'm the pday girl in the world
the 33 year old singer looked chic in a
pink dress with a thigh-high slit
heels and a leather jacket with a
matching fuzzy pink bucket hat
meanwhile the 32 year old rapper rocked
a purple shirt
and leather pants a source tells et that
the two had so much fun
playing arcade games with friends until
3 am
i love it according to the source they
enjoyed some friendly competition
challenging each other to arcade games
adding that they both had their guard
down
and were genuinely happy and having a
blast
and the picks prove it just check out
the love birds grinning ear to ear
and smooching it up
and if all that wasn't cute enough
photographers caught the two
walking together outside with rocky's
arm around his leading lady
e.t recently spoke to the rapper about
his documentary stockholm syndrome
and he talked about having his superstar
girlfriend support
it's amazing and i'm honestly truly
blessed real
you know and back in may rocky opened up
about his relationship with riri in the
june july issue of gq
calling her the love of his life and
quote my lady
rocky told the mag quote relationships
are so much better when you got the one
she amounts to probably like a million
of the other ones
and he doubled down on all that the one
talk sweetly saying quote
i think when you know you know she's the
one
shortly after that a source told et
about their crazy connection
quote rihanna is asap rocky's dream girl
and
has been for a while he's so in love
with her and they have the best time
together
et source added they're always laughing
but also connect with each other on a
deep level
quote they just get each other whether
it comes to their senses of humor or
career aspirations and
more they have a crazy connection and
chemistry and are such a cute
fun loving couple rumors of romance
between them first sparked last july
when riri featured rocky in her fenty
skin
campaign to me in in the industry he's
one of the guys that like
everybody loves their skin i mean i've
always wanted to know how the heck
do you have better skin like half these
girls i mean like what what do you do
at the time the umbrella singer opened
up to et about why she chose him for her
ads
i wanted men to be represented because
this
skincare line is gender neutral and so i
needed that male representation
in the campaign and so rocky and nan
nazax we wanted that male representation
so
men knew that it was okay by winter a
source confirmed the news to et that the
musicians were in fact
a couple quote they have always had
amazing chemistry and rihanna relates to
asap
and it feels natural easy and fun